to adapt a screenplay from an existing
work as an even more demanding
discipline than writing
and original the conscientious adapter
tries to please himself or herself as
well as the author of the original book
or play or story and if you can't do
that at least please the producer who
gave him the job sometimes the writer
who wrote the original is also one who
does the adaptation as our two of this
year's nominees all of the nominees for
Best Screenplay based on material
previously produced or published are
and yes go Holland for Europa Europa
based on the memoirs of Salomon Carell
Fannie Flagg and Carole sobieski for
fried green tomatoes based on the novel
fried green tomatoes whistles stop cafe
by Fannie Flagg Oliver Stone and Sakura
Squire for JFK based on the books on the
trail of the assassins by Jim Garrison
and crossfire the plot that killed
Kennedy by Jim Morris
Pat Conroy and Becky Johnson for the
Prince of tides based on the novel by
Pat Conroy Ted tally for the Silence of
the Lambs based on the novel by Thomas
Harris the Oscar goes to
Ted tally for the silence of the land
thank you to the Academy for recognizing
me among such distinguished colleagues
you can't reach for one of these without
standing on the shoulders of giants and
my own particular giants are Tom Harris
who so graciously lent me his brilliant
novel and Jonathan Demi a director of
Awesome talent and generosity and one of
the finest men I've ever known my
heartfelt admiration and gratitude to
both of those gentlemen thanks also to
Jodie Foster Toni Hopkins Scott Glenn
for their astonishing performances and
to the extraordinary family of artists
and craftsmen who so honored my work
with their own thanks to my producer
Zedd Saxon Kenneth utt Ron Bozeman Gary
gets minh the executives and staff of
Ryan Pictures past and present for their
spectacular support to my inspiring
agents Arlene Donovan and Patti Detroit
and thanks most of all to my teachers my
friends and to my wonderful and loving
family prized beyond measure
Melinda Austin I love you all good
things to those who wait thank